there was this hilarious video this
summer about him and joic in Serbia in
the summer and they was like some horse
race is this dude really like obsessed
with horses yeah man Joker all offseason
is in Serbia drinking beer and watching
horses he definitely likes horses more
than basketball man we'll be in there
getting ready for practice at training
camp and he's on his phone watching the
horse races he probably didn't touch a
basketball all offseason and somehow he
got better and then that's who AG is as
a person he'll travel in offseason by
himself so I know he pulled up on Joker
and I know they had a good time out
there in I think I'm going try to get
out there next year see what yoke has
going just see the culture out there he
tells me like it's fun out there he says
the night life is way better than it is
over here so I'm going go turn up with
Joker do
[Music]
that